NOMINATION FOR 3 MINUTES OF
WORK, THREE, RAYMOND A RURAL
EXPLAINS IT IN
"SEEN AND UNSEEN," BUT FIRST, DO
YOU KNOW HIS NAME?
THAT IS THE FOCUS OF TONIGHT’S
"ANGLE."
THAT QUESTION WAS POSED BY
ACTIVISTS AND PROTESTERS FOR
WEEKS AFTER THE KILLING OF
GEORGE FLOYD.
IT WAS MEANT TO JAR THE NATION
INTO FOCUSING ON POLICE
BRUTALITY.
AND IT WORKED, FLOYD’S NAME AND
MESSAGE BECAME SYNONYMOUS WITH
THE SUFFERING THAT COMES FROM
RACIAL INJUSTICE.
OF COURSE, HIS BROTHER USED HIS
NAME FOR THEIR OWN TWISTED
POLITICAL AGENDA.
AS A BURNING DOWN THE CITIES
WOULD BRING MR. FLOYD BACK OR
SOLVE UNDERLYING PROBLEMS.
OF COURSE, IT MERELY MADE
MATTERS WORSE.
IN THE INTERVENING WEEKS SINCE
THE UPHEAVAL IN LATE MAY, MANY
MORE AFRICAN-AMERICAN FAMILIES
HAVE LOST LOVED ONES TO
VIOLENCE.
AT LEAST 144 HAVE BEEN MURDERED
SINCE JUNE 1ST IN CHICAGO ALONE,
INCLUDING THESE CHILDREN.
3-YEAR-OLD, 1-YEAR-OLD,
7-YEAR-OLD NATALIA, ALL SHOT
DEAD.
BUT UNLIKE WITH GEORGE FLOYD,
THE GENERAL PUBLIC WON’T
REMEMBER THEM.
BECAUSE THE ACTIVISTS DON’T FIND
THEIR STORIES USEFUL.
IN THE MEDIA ALSO PUSHING A
POLITICAL AGENDA, THEY BASICALLY
JUST JOHN.
LAST WEEKEND IN MILWAUKEE, A
WELL-KNOWN PASSIONATE FIGURE IN
THE COMMUNITY, SOMEONE WHO
SUPPORTED EVERY ISSUE FROM
POLICE REFORM AND OTHER LIBERAL
CAUSES, BUT LATELY THEY HAVE
BEEN HOLDING PRO MADE TRUMP
SIGNS.
THAT MAN WAS MURDERED.
HE ALSO HAPPENED TO BE
AFRICAN-AMERICAN.
HE WAS SHOT AND KILLED OUTSIDE
OF HIS OFFICE JUST THIS
AFTERNOON WHILE HE WAS SITTING
IN A LAWN CHAIR.
IT HAPPENED IN BROAD DAYLIGHT.
DO YOU KNOW HIS NAME?
I BET YOU DON’T.
IT IS BERNELL TRAMMELL.
>> I SAW THE COPS PULL UP.
THE VANS, AMBULANCES,
FIREFIGHTERS.
WE SAT AND WATCHED AND THEY GAVE
CPR 15-20 MINUTES.
>> Laura: SECURITY CAMERAS
CAPTURE THESE IMAGES OF THE
SUSPECT, AND THE POLICE ARE
CONTINUING TO INVESTIGATE.
BUT THE MILWAUKEE CENTRAL
JOURNAL REPORTED A FEW DAYS AGO
THAT REGGIE MOORE DIRECTOR OF
MILWAUKEE’S OFFICE OF VIOLENT
PREVENTION SAID HE RECENTLY
INTERVENED IN A DISPUTE BETWEEN
BERNELL TRAMMELL AND A YOUNG
MAN.
HE THOUGHT THE INCIDENT WAS
RELATED TO A TRUMP SIGNS THAT
BERNELL TRAMMELL WAS CARING AND
RON JOHNSON A REPUBLICAN TWEETED
THIS ON THE NEWS OF
MR. TRAMMELL’S TRAGIC DEATH.
HE WAS KNOWN TO MANY IN
MILWAUKEE AND MY CONDOLENCES TO
HIS FAMILY AND FRIENDS.
I HOPE THEY GET ANSWERS AND
JUSTICE SOON.
WELL, YOU PROBABLY WON’T BE
SURPRISED TO KNOW THE MAJOR
NETWORKS OUTSIDE OF FOX DID NOT
MENTION THIS HORRIFIC MURDER,
NOT A PEEP FROM CNN, MSNBC,
"THE WASHINGTON POST," ABC NEWS,
CBS NEWS OR NBC.
AND THEY YOU TO BURST TO PICK UP
THE FLAK AND ASK BASIC QUESTIONS
QUESTIONS.
>> I CAN’T FOR THE LIFE OF ME
FATHOM HOW IT IS JUSTIFIED, THAT
JUST BECAUSE SOMEBODY IS A TRUMP
SUPPORTER, THAT THEY GET SHOT
DOWN IN COLD BLOOD AND THEY’VE
NEVER, EVER DONE ANYTHING TO
ANYBODY OTHER THAN EXPRESS THEIR
OPINIONS.
I EVEN WONDER IF THE MAINSTREAM
MEDIA IS GOING TO GIVE IT THE
AMOUNT OF COVERAGE THAT IT HAS
GIVEN SOME CRIMINALS OUT THERE
THAT HAVE DIED IN THE STREETS.
BECAUSE THEY CERTAINLY DON’T
GIVE IT TO THE CHILDREN.
THEY DON’T GET THE COVERAGE.
>> Laura: NO, THEY DON’T.
AND NO ONE KNOWS THEIR NAMES.
LIKE I SAID.
BUT THOSE VICTIMS ARE PEOPLE
TOO.
LIKE MR. TRAMMELL WAS.
>> THAT GUY WAS JUST FULL OF
LOVE.
>> HE WAS JUST A COMMUNITY
FIGURE.
WE WENT TONIGHT
"THE INGRAHAM ANGLE" HAS
EXCLUSIVE VIDEO OF HIS
INTERACTION DAYS BEFORE HIS
MURDER THAT MAY SHED LIGHT ON
WHAT WAS MOTIVATING THE
HOMICIDE.
>> OBAMA HAS DONE NOTHING FOR
US.
EVERYBODY SAY HEALTH CARE, WE
CAN AFFORD HEALTH CARE.
WE AIN’T GOT NO MONEY.
SO TRUMP AT LEAST WHETHER THE
WILL OF GOD OR HIS OWN
INSPIRATION TO DO SOMETHING THAT
NO PRESIDENT HAS EVER DONE, AND
THAT IS WHY YOU GOT MY VOTE.
I GET MY [BLEEP] THROWN AT ME
BEST.
AT BEST.
>> NO FEAR, COME AT ME.
>> WELL, IT AIN’T RIGHT BUT AT
THE SAME TIME COME AMERICA,
FREEDOM OF EXPRESSION.
>> Laura: IF YOU KNOW, HE
SEEMED TO TRULY BELIEVE THAT.
WE WILL AIR MORE OF THAT VIDEO
LATER IN THE SHOWN.
BUT AT THE VERY LEAST, ESTHER
TRAMMELL WAS AWARE HE COULD BE
HOME FOR HIS PRO-TRUMP VIEWS.
IF THIS IS TRUE, IT IS
ABSOLUTELY APPALLING AS IS THE
DEAFENING SILENCE FROM DEMOCRATS
DEMOCRATS.
WHERE IS AL SHARPTON?
WHERE IS BLACK LIVES MATTER?
A GROUP THAT MR. TRAMMELL
SUPPORTED, BY THE WAY.
BUT THEY ARE NOWHERE TO BE
FOUND.
APPARENTLY CERTAIN BLACK LIVES
DO NOT MATTER.
LET’S NOT FORGET THE LEFT, LONG
HISTORY OF IGNORING VILIFYING OR
DEHUMANIZING BLACKS WHO
DISAGREE.
THEY ARE CALLED UNCLE TOM’S WERE
RACE TRADERS.
THEY ARE NOT AUTHENTIC.
JUST LIKE BIDEN SAID YOU ARE NOT
REALLY BLACK IF YOU’RE NOT A
DEMOCRAT.
TWICE, NBC HOST HAS PROVED MY
POINT.
HAS DONALD TRUMP EVER PROMISED
ANYTHING FINANCIALLY FOR YOUR
BLIND SUPPORT OF THIS
ADMINISTRATION OR HELPING HIS
CAMPAIGN?
>> NO HIM AND I’VE KNOWN HIM
SINCE 2015.
>> A CAMPAIGN SURROGATE?
YOU WANT TO ASK ME THAT BECAUSE
I DON’T --
>> Laura: I WOULD LIKE TO TURN
THE QUESTION ON AN ANCHOR AND
ARE YOU A CAMPAIGN SURROGATE
PAID FOR THE BIDEN CAMPAIGN?
HOW INSULTING IS THIS.
HOW DEMEANING.
YOU DIDN’T THINK THIS WAY ON
YOUR OWN.
YOU COULDN’T HAVE COME TO THIS
CONCLUSION ON YOUR OWN, USING
YOUR OWN INTELLECT.
THINK ABOUT THAT.
THE DEMOCRATS AND THEIR RADICAL
MEDIA COLLABORATORS HAVE BEEN
PULLING A CON ON
AFRICAN-AMERICANS FOR DECADES.
THE PARTY OF SLAVERY AND JIM
CROW, THE PARTY OF SEGREGATION
AND THE KKK HAVE WORKED OVERTIME
TO COVER UP ITS OWN SENSE IN
ORDER TO ONCE AGAIN TO FIGHT US
ON RACIAL AND ETHNIC LINES.
NO DOING SO REQUIRES THAT THEY
DEMONIZE, DISENFRANCHISE, IT D
PLATFORM AND DEHUMANIZE
AMERICANS WHO DISAGREE.
BUT THEY KNOW THAT WE ARE ONTO
THEM AND THEIR SICK GAME THAT
MORE MINORITIES ARE SEEN THROUGH
THEIR SLOGAN AREA OF BLACK LIVES
MATTER WHEN IN FACT THEY ACT
LIKE ONLY CERTAIN LIVES MATTER.
MORE DECENT PEOPLE, I BELIEVE
ARE SEEING THE PATHETIC FAILURE
IN LEADERSHIP IN DEMOCRAT RUN
CITIES.
THERE ARE BLACK AND IMMIGRANT
OWNED BUSINESSES ARE DESTROYED
WITH OHMIC IMPUNITY.
AND ANTI-TRUMP HATRED THAT THEY
DO MORE TO PROTECT THE RIGHTS OF
VIOLENT PROTESTERS THAN THEY DO
WITH THE RIGHTS OF THEIR OWN
LAW-ABIDING RESIDENTS.
NOW COME ON OCCASION, A FEW
HONEST DEMOCRATS WILL SPEAK OUT.
AS HAPPENED WITH A
MAYOR LIGHTFOOT LAST MONTH.
>> WE HAVE TO COME UP WITH A
BETTER PLAN BECAUSE ONCE MY FEAR
IS, ONCE THEY ARE DONE LOOTING
AND RIOTING, WHATEVER IS GOING
TO HAPPEN TONIGHT, WHAT ARE WE
GOING TO DO AND WHAT ARE WE
GOING TO TELL OUR RESIDENTS WITH
GOOD-FAITH PEOPLE TO STAND UP.
IS THAT GOING TO BE ENOUGH?
>> THANK YOU.
NEXT QUESTION.
>> NO COME I WANT AN ANSWER.
YOU COMMENTED, I WANT AN ANSWER.
>> I THINK YOUR QUESTION IS FULL
OF [BLEEP].
>> Laura: DID YOU GET THAT?
TO A DEMOCRAT, YOU ARE 100% FULL
OF [BLEEP] YOU KNOW WHAT.
IT DOESN’T HAVE TO BE THIS WAY.
AFRICAN-AMERICANS, LATINOS FROM
OTHER IMMIGRANTS WHO JUST WANT
WHAT EVERYONE ELSE WANTS.
THEY WANT A FAIR SHOT, THEY WANT
DECENT SCHOOLS, THEY WANT SAFE
STREETS.
THEY CAN WALK AWAY FROM THE
PARTY THAT IS TAKING THEM FOR
GRANTED AND ABUSED THEIR TRUST
AND SUPPORT FOR AN AGENDA THAT
ACTUALLY WILL RESPECT THEIR
FREEDOM TO MAKE THEIR OWN
CHOICES AND TO BELIEVE WHATEVER
THEY WANT.
SAFE STREETS.
BUT FOR NOW, TRAMMELL WASN’T
KILLED BY A CORRUPT POLICE
OFFICER.
HE WAS CUT DOWN IN THE MIDDLE OF